[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
different things are useful to one
another in different ways but all things
are mutually serviceable through their
own nature that is through being related
to the absolute in two ways the one
positive whereby they exist entirely on
their own account the other negative
whereby they exist for others the
relation to absolute being or religion
is therefore of all useful things the
supremely useful for it is the pure
utility itself it is this enduring being
of all things or their being in and for
themselves and it is their downfall or
their being for another
paragraph 561 is rather short it's just
a set of sentences and it doesn't appear
like there's that much going on there
but this is an important as I've said
about so many other paragraphs
transition point where we are moving
from this newly introduced idea of
usefulness or here mutual service
ability things being knit sleek for each
other being being useful having a kind
of utility if you want to use that word
and the relation to the absolute here in
terms of religion and it's let's call it
what it is a dialectic with
enlightenment so Hegel tells us two main
things here he's further characterizing
what it means for things to be useful
for each other and I think there's a bit
of unpacking to do there and then what
is this particular absolute like so he
says different things are useful to one
another in different ways okay that's
almost a truth right different things
have different uses but is there some
sort of essence to service ability
usefulness mutual serviceable yeah
status right was there some sort of
thing that's heis them together Hegel
says yes but notice that this is not an
analysis like that of say Aristotle you
know what is the useful good the bonum
util a the you know the the good that is
not really good in itself not
intrinsically good but a good that leads
to other goods and is thereby called
good almost derivative ly in that
respect one that we can come to mistake
for being genuinely good Hegel doesn't
go that way what does Hegel say instead
he talks in these very metaphysical
terms he says all things are mutually
serviceable that is serviceable in
relation to each other
so already we we no longer have a kind
of hierarchy of means towards certain
ends of useful goods useful things for
certain ends that are good in themselves
things that we desire for their own sake
says they all are mutually useful and he
uses the word digna here so it can be
people it can be products it can be
processes this is just a generic term he
says that they're mutually serviceable
in their nature or here these them their
essence and what makes them what they
are so he says they're mutually
serviceable through being related to the
absolute in two ways how are they
related to the absolute so what he
sketches out here is two ways in which
they don't seem to be related to the
absolute right he talks about them
existing on their own account which
means that they've got their own being
apart from the absolute but maybe
they're part of the absolute or a moment
in the absolute right they have this on
and firs eyx helps design so it's not
just on infers I'm right on and fuzzy
accepts and there's actually a zoo in
there sign to exist for itself to be for
itself and then that zelf intensifies it
this is like truly having your own being
almost like being absolute with a small
case a so everything's got that and then
everything also exists not just for
another right but for others existing
for others an entire range no longer
just this other but any other in general
through on design
how is this being related to the
absolute well the thing partakes in the
absoluteness of the absolute you might
say and it exists for others it is
connected with others it engages it
offers itself as something useful for
others and it's precisely this now now
think back to the dialectic of
self-consciousness why was it that
self-consciousness which was revealed to
be big eared a hunger desire could not
be satisfied with the same material
product that it could you know enjoy
itself in you know eating or rolling
around in mud or whatever it happens to
be why did it need another
self-consciousness because it needed
something that had a certain kind of
stability a certain kind of
sophisticated structure something that
was like itself that it then could
demand from could dominate could make
give up its own essence and become the
less essential partner in the pairing
here this is what everything is doing
and offering to everything else Hegel is
saying so let's go on to the second part
here again very short paragraph he says
the relation to absolute being or
religion that's kind of an interesting
transition there isn't it the relation
to absolute being or religion religion
is this relation to the absolute being
see faith coming back on the scene but
also pure insight and the Enlightenment
associated with it because remember that
also had its own sort of religiosity
towards the absolute being considered as
void - all the predicates he says is
therefore of all things of all useful
things the supremely useful religion
becomes something useful and I mean
hasn't that been the case for
a long time put aside conspiracy
theories that find the origin of
religion just in social control and
let's just assume for a minute that
religion is really a stretching out as
Hegel thinks it is towards something
that that is absolute something that is
divine it might not be something that is
exactly as we conceive of it and it
definitely is not going to be you know
the picture of you know God in the sky
with a no you know long beard or stuff
like that but Hegel thinks there is
something there that religion is aiming
at so how can that be useful well it can
be in fact useful for social control but
it can be useful for people in so many
other ways it can even be useful in
terms of trying to figure out well where
do I fit in this cosmos this universe
there's a number of different ways so
the absolute becomes the thing that is
most useful which means that it exists
for others right so he says it becomes
or it is pure utility itself it is this
enduring being of all things or there
being in and for selves and it is the
their downfall their being for another
so what we saw is okay this question
that was posed to us well how are these
two positive and negative ways of being
related to the absolute how are they
actually being related to the absolute
the absolute itself understood here as
or through religion has these these
things also on infer is the exult sign
and for Andre's ein being for another
giving of itself to another allowing the
other to determine it and at the same
time being what it is in itself with a
relation of intensive reflexivity so
this is an important transition point as
I pointed out where is this going to
lead well we'll see
- faith of course this positive outcome
of enlightenment is just as much an
abomination as its negative attitude
towards belief this enlightened insight
into absolute being which sees nothing
in it but just absolute being the ethel
supremum or the void this intention to
regard everything in its immediate
existence as having intrinsic being or
as good and finally to regard the
relation of the individual conscious
being to absolute being religion as
exhaustively expressed in the notion of
utility all this is for faith utterly
detestable this wisdom peculiar to
enlightenment at the same time
necessarily seems to faith to be
undiluted platitude and the confession
of platitude because it consists of
knowing nothing of absolute being or
what amounts to the same to the same
thing and knowing this quite flat truism
about it just that it is only absolute
being and on the other hand in knowing
only what is finite and moreover knowing
it is truth and thinking that this
knowledge of the finite as true is the
highest knowledge attainable
in paragraph 562 we see the mutual
antagonism that has been developing this
entire time between faith on the one
hand and pure insight or the
enlightenment on the other hand continue
to play itself out but now in terms of
this concept of usefulness which gets
rejected by faith as something that is
characteristic particularly
characteristic of the pure insight that
is driving the enlightenment so what do
we have going on here Hegel tells us if
we take the side or take the viewpoint
of faith this positive outcome of
enlightenment this positive outcome
meaning a realization about the nature
of the supreme being the absolute being
which we saw earlier is a being that can
only be conceived of in some sense as a
void as a you know being lacking
predicate and yet at the same time as
something supremely good because it is
in the last paragraph the most useful
thing all right faith looks at this
perspective as well as the you know
sensualism we could say of the
Enlightenment to focus on the here and
now as well as on what we can call goods
of sense and the connection between
these as what Hegel here is calling a
kind of abomination faith is not happy
about this so he says this positive
outcome is as much an abomination as its
negative attitude towards belief so it's
not just the negative position on belief
saying listen you know you might be
doing something kind of like science or
kind of like philosophy but you're
you're not doing it very well because
you're doing this picture thinking thing
you know thanks for taking the ball this
far
I'll take it at this point and move it
forward yeah I feel like other sports
metaphors time for you to pass the baton
on and let the rest of us run with it
that's one aspect but this this
worldview that the Enlightenment is
putting forth this explanation of where
the human being fits within the cosmos
that is equally as offensive to faith
and you might say well why why is that
so offensive to faith well in part
because what its ruling out is any sort
of you might say imaginable intelligible
relation of the human being to a rich
divine not just a being lacking
predicate I mean this is the sort of
thing where you could say you know who
would be a great example of what's
counting as enlightenment here Descartes
you know if you think about dick Hart's
God what do you actually know about God
the absolute being and the rest of the
things in the world looking at dick
Hart's work okay we've got two kinds of
substances actually three because God is
is another kind of substance extension
known through our senses also cog nine
and the pure thought and what does God
do God is a being that has all
perfections but does it Descartes really
discuss these perfections very much what
are the ones that he needs well he needs
goodness to get things off the ground
and isn't it useful that God can give us
a world that then we can say okay thanks
God see you later
let's focus on the world that we can
understand through science so to improve
it through the three M's you know
mechanics morals and medicine coming
from the the tree of the tree trunk of
physics coming from the roots of
metaphysics right we could pick other
thinkers as well but I like to Kurt in
part because Pascal had that great line
about him Descartes needed
God as just a fillip to get everything
going and then once that was done he
didn't really have much use for him at
that point so the perspective of faith
he says this enlightened insight into
absolute being which sees nothing in it
but just absolute being the at supreme
in French right
why is Hegel using the etsu Prime
because a lot of the thinking about this
is going on in French you know in some
respects at the time that he is writing
this the French are you know further
along this line in the you know free
thinking and atheism and enlightenment
then the Germans are matter of fact to
some degree the English and the Scots
are as well right so the episode Prem or
the void he says so enlightenment he
says has an intention to regard
everything in its immediate existence as
having intrinsic being or as good and
what does that mean it looks at as we
saw just a few paragraphs earlier at
every single thing as being what it is
through the senses we have this return
to sense certainty when he's talking
about the thing in its immediate
existence that is what the reference is
for enlightenment and you might say well
wait that doesn't apply to everybody
because you know decart for example
thinks there's also the the world of you
know the mind of the SP right mind or
spirit and that's not the same thing as
sense descartes really stresses the
difference between the senses and the
imagination and the intellect but
descartes also says you know you can
maybe use your intellect you know
unaided without connecting it to it's an
imagination maybe an hour a year maybe
more if you're if you're particularly
clear-headed and lucky so much of what's
going on even with somebody you know
who's a duelist like Descartes is a
focus on the immediate on the rural
of cents and what it can provide us the
things within it that are useful so in a
way you know Hegel's not saying this
here but the you know faith might look
at it as to use a you know word that we
have used in the 20th century quite a
bit a DeMuth ologies door disenchanted
world a world that lacks some of the
richness of meaning that was there in
the picture thinking the representation
the force telling that was
characteristic of faith so he goes out
of me and he says this intention to
regard everything okay finally to regard
the relation of the individual conscious
being to absolute being religion as
exhaustively expressed in the notion of
utility so we should talk a little bit
more about that I brought that up in the
previous paragraph how is religion for
the Enlightenment encompassed in the
notion of utility I brought up how
religion might serve certain purposes
without meaning to or at least without
at first intending to but then perhaps
the religious people realize that like
for example social control or providing
a common context of meaning and
certainty for people or providing some
sort of meaningful understanding of
one's life and the suffering within it
for an individual or giving somebody a
set of ethical principles and guidelines
and rules to help keep them in line and
help them develop okay so that would be
understanding religion in the terms of
well that winds up being what its
function is even if religion doesn't
understand itself that way what happens
in the Enlightenment is
they don't completely get rid of
religion I mean there are some
enlightenment philosophers or like
religion all problematic get rid of all
of it but you notice that even like in
the French Revolution there is a new
religion a religion of the Epsom M which
resembles what Eagles talking about here
great example of this by the way would
be somebody who's not French but English
well actually English and then American
this is American citizenship Thomas
Paine if you've never read the age of
reason it's an interesting book Paine
was the dais
that that's an Enlightenment viewpoint
that holds that you know very much to
this sort of idea God is is something
that you know we can't really know that
much about except by using reason and
much of that is sort of stripping away
all the the nonsense that the religious
people have put onto it much of the the
book the age of reason is devoted to
showing how scripture is unreliable is
it's essentially repeating the same sort
of arguments that Spinoza was was giving
in in the you know the trekked hottest
halo be called politicus and that thomas
hobbes also and david hume a little bit
later are giving about these sorts of
things about reliability but what's
really interesting about it Paine write
this book because he doesn't want the
French in the French Revolution to
become atheists because if they do that
everything will be lost the revolution
will not really make sense everything
that they gain will fall into ruins and
anarchy and it'll be human against human
and you know everything that was bad
before will just show up with with more
ferocity so what is going to prevent
that get away from that crazy Catholic
religion and the French masses should
convert to deism so Paine writes this
book and I think that that's very
typical of many Enlightenment thinkers
and their views on things now coming
back to this issue right so I said we
religion and it might serve some sort of
social purpose with the Enlightenment
there is this conception that maybe
religion could serve those purposes much
better if it wasn't reformed the way the
Protestants did it but reformed in a
much more radical way and I mean if
you've read some of the Protestant
reformers and you're saying something
like in a more radical way what's that
you know well it would rely on pure
reason and so we see some really
interesting projects don't we like for
example Kant's religion within the
limits of Pure Reason all right which
essentially is a book less of religion
and more of ethics Paine's age of reason
as I pointed out Locke's reasonableness
of Christianity all these attempts to
say let's take Christian religion and
we'll be Christianize it except for the
parts that we like you know another
example that would be Jefferson and the
Bible that that he creates by I think it
might have just been the gospel by
cutting out all the parts where any sort
of miracle takes place so you're left
with just the ethical content religion
should be turned in this point of view
religion the relation to the absolute
being into something essentially useful
not just that happens to be useful do
you see that the difference there not
just that happens to serve certain
functions but something that is at its
core made useful where usefulness for
human development for for ethics for
whatever it's going to be becomes the
criterion for what is true and what is
false what is believable and what is to
be rejected what is to be done and what
is not to be done within the religion
this is a very radical way of
understanding things so faith doesn't
really like this right and so Hegel goes
the enemy says
all of this is for faith utterly
detestable what's utterly detestable the
attacks on faith the view of the
absolute being is having no predicates
as being just this pure being the
sensualism that that's expressed over
here and then understanding things in
terms of utilities so there's sort of a
four fold thing that is ticking off the
religious people and understandably so
so he says the this wisdom peculiar to
enlightenment from the perspective of
faith he says it seemed necessarily
seems to be undiluted platitude what is
platitude that's when people are saying
things sort of you know and this is
really quite interesting because what is
what is one of the big critiques that we
have of religious people ah you just
utter platitudes you know a great
example of this today is you know we
have these these terrible atrocities
that take place in school shootings
hospital shootings you know we have
other things that happen as well with
natural disasters and then people post
our thoughts and prayers are with them
and a lot of people are like I don't
want your damn thoughts and prayers that
doesn't help me at all that's just a
platitude you're not gonna actually do
anything in the world you're just gonna
mumble to yourself and make yourself
feel good by talking about you know
thoughts and prayers okay so that's
something that can be said against
people of faith right here we have that
being said about the Enlightenment from
the perspective of the people of faith
saying you guys are just talking a good
game but you're not really going to
follow through on this you're not that
interested in you know improving the lot
of the peasant or helping them deal with
the fact that you know their kids are
dying you you know your content to like
give them some stuff about how
everything is useful and things are
arranged the best and you know progress
is going to make this this sort of thing
go away eventually how the hell
does that help any of them in the
circumstances that they're in this I
mean there's only one you know example
of what it is that somebody motivated by
faith might actually say so these are
platitudes for faith and he says and the
confession of platitude what is the
confession of platitude mean saying this
is this is all we've got this is this is
all that we have and in a certain sense
they're right the Enlightenment has
always been something you know in
development it's always been something
that doesn't really exist but is being
proposed as a new blueprint a new plan
you know it did exist in certain ways we
can say right so he goes on and he says
it consists in knowing nothing of
absolute being or what account what
amounts to the same thing and knowing
there's quite flat truism about it just
that it is only absolute being what does
it focus on what does it spend its time
with if it doesn't worry about the
absolute being because the absolute
being will sort itself out and the
absolute being created this world for us
to work our our stuff out in and make
progress and you know God that God
doesn't need any prayers God just needs
us to follow the moral law and do some
science and make things better for his
or its or her creatures well then we
focus on the world we focus on the human
beings and we focus on all the other
things we focus on the natural world
that we understand through the senses
and through science and natural
philosophy so he says on the other hand
in knowing only what is finite and
moreover here's where it gets really
interesting knowing it as truth and
thinking that this knowledge of the
finite is true is the highest knowledge
attainable if that's the case then faith
at best was just sort of doing primitive
science but getting it wrong or
primitive social
science or whatever you want to say but
as the world improves as our science
improves as our attention to the human
being and to all the other finite things
of the world's world gets gets you know
more and more systematized and tested we
get rid of this this stuff this is just
old residue that we don't need around
anymore it's just taking up and it's
taking up not empty space but space that
could be empty to put something good
there so you know get rid of the
churches or turn them into work houses
or laboratories or whatever you like
faith understandably sees something that
it doesn't like there and it is
criticizing the Enlightenment
perspective in this way
you